Fox News has again played host to more
weaponized disinformation this time it's
coming from Fox News contributor Bill
Bennett he's a conservative who's been
around a very long time and Bennett
trotted out some of the same tired
boring talking points that just
titillate the Fox News audience
including this is like a flu and this is
not a pandemic let's look at the video
straight away then we'll break it down
bill what are we missing about this
virus we see the numbers 22,000 dead how
many cases but you took a step back and
what did you find yeah let's take a step
back the estimates now from the
University of Washington which is the
model everybody's been going on even
though it's been wrong most of the time
by a lot overstating it is now they say
60,000 people will die 61 thousand is
what we lost to the flu in 2017 and 2018
the flu now we all regret the loss of 61
thousand people if that's what it turns
out to be I'm gonna tell you I think
it's going to be less and salute all
those who are working in the frontlines
on this the hospital workers the nurses
the doctors etc and the generai see the
American people but if you look at those
numbers and see the comparable we're
gonna have fewer fatalities from this
than from the flu for this we scared the
hell out of the American people we lost
17 million jobs we put a major dent in
the economy we closed down the schools
you heard dr. oz say we probably had
enough to do that shut down the churches
and so on you know this was not and is
not a pandemic but we do have a panic
and pandemonium as a result of the hype
of this so we can't let him get Gallup
this is a debate tactic where you just
throw out a ton of stuff and it all
sounds difficult to refute we've got to
break it down piece by piece first bill
bennett says if 60,000 people die this
won't have been serious remember if only
60,000 died in the first wave were
expecting two to three waves it will be
because we did all of the stuff he says
we didn't have to do already mentioned
it earlier this is the anti-vaxxer
conundrum without doing anything the
death toll could have been a middle
million and a half two million we don't
know
next measles I'm sorry not measles he
compares it to the flu not to measles he
says you know sixty thousand are going
to die from the flu and sixty thousand
are going to die of coronavirus and
that's related in some way in his mind
this has nothing to do with the flu
in that the seasonal flu is not a
pandemic you have to understand the
difference between a pandemic flu like
that of 1918 or the seasonal flu you can
have a flu that is a pandemic but the
current seasonal flu is not the seasonal
flu happens seasonally you've got some
immunity because of vaccination and
previous exposure you have a much
smaller death rate there are plenty of
functioning antivirals for the seasonal
flu it doesn't have a huge impact on the
public at large it doesn't require an
economic shutdown to prevent it from
going logarithmic it doesn't overwhelm
the medical system now of course you can
have a pandemic flu
we had one in 1918 this year's flu is
not a pandemic flu SARS Co v2 is not
seasonal in any strict sense without
mitigation it goes logarithmic and to
some degree it has we don't have a
vaccine we don't have partial immunity
it has a much higher death rate than the
seasonal flu we don't have functioning
antivirals and it has overwhelmed
medical systems so in reality what we
have right now is like a pandemic flu
but not like the seasonal flu if you
don't understand the difference between
a pandemic flu and a seasonal flu you
might fall for this nonsense and the
really scary thing is that there was a
time when Bill Bennett was taken
seriously and even considered to be a
great thinker by many on the right hard
to imagine I know this is another one of
these not a doctor not a scientist
situations but they still get to say
things on Fox News weaponized scary
stuff